well you big man I've been waiting on
your ass
sorry about that I had to pick up this
book to figure out my 2-way got my shoe
shot a brand new shirt chili Palmer said
he was gonna call about my audition yeah
he's called about that big Simone [ __ ]
movie he's making yeah come on man
Linda moon play big with Aerosmith so so
what you talking so so she's gonna be a
star man and what does a star need but a
manager Chili's a manager that's why we
gotta take his ass out man look chili
Palmer served his purpose he got Linda
with ariseth COO now we got to take over
Elliott we got to put chili Palmer
out the record business permanently this
next idea man why would you play me like
that that happens to be an idea that me
and Nick appropriated together for your
information your problem is you spend
your whole day walking around your
apartment wondering whether or not your
ass looks fat in your pants you don't
even know how bidness man thinks that
man stole my act Elliot and he
disrespected me Roger he did the same
goddamn thing to you to fruity pebble no
respect
and put you up in a movie elliott
promised me a call
hey he's clowning you he's even making
no damn movie that's how stupid you are
he's just playing you like a [ __ ]
Elliot he's using you for information
and whatnot
well we gotta take chili Palmer out man
we get Linda back with me and Nicky
didn't get mad money rolling here man we
got so much money to put you to all dere
movie Samoan alone I hear them kids at
the Johnson theatre nah man Oh does that
Simone by himself you know I'm saying Oh
dad don't go in there Samoan oh [ __ ] the
Samoans gonna go in I'm telling you man
I see it
what if Nikki's just using you to get
what he wants what if he's busting your
balls if he's busting my balls that'd be
the last thing he remembers Eddie yeah
what was it 3:00 p.m. what okay bye good
news yeah what it's the queen of scream
bonnibel yes oh that's what I'm talkin
about a little bit drive with some
little blues mix and a little old-school
mixed with the new-school your you got
it goin on that's right for real you
know I gotta tell you patty this is just
so cool you know I'm I'm an older woman
real old honey but I haven't done some
of the things you've done I was reading
all the stuff that you're doing like you
grabbed a spot with Errol Smith and to
do a big gig like that you have to have
chops of a queen and you have chops of a
queen you can sing your butt off it
won't be big
no I'm trying you know it's it's just
amazing you know first it's Aerosmith
and now I'm getting ready to shoot my
first music video Wow yeah for this song
oh okay let me say something now who are
some of your biggest influences oh well
I would definitely say my dad yeah and
you of course don't you say that because
I'm sitting across from your girlfriend
I don't want to have to beat you down I
swear
and I'm also I'm a big fan of sinless
all so Pharrell was like it was such a
huge honor when I got to work with him
and with high Gordon she's amazing that
was her latest single ain't no reason
and there ain't no reason for you not to
love that song right now we're gonna
listen to that hit
one more time this time you ready
don't forget to breathe what's the
matter chili I'm not ready for this
what did you do with the Viper Room
before you went on do that look that was
different
I had the chicks now it's just me on
stage on my own
I got news for you the only reason
people want to see the chicks was
because of you
yeah but what if they don't like myself
why should they like me look at me I'm
the one telling you like it is you're
beautiful
you're talented you're ambitious and
more importantly you're a good person so
you know what I say why not you and you
got one other thing what's that me
so you'll do great but before you become
a Devo
why don't you perform first first guy
says are you busting my balls then I say
if I was busting your balls
ok hey great job
oh thanks chilly I'm glad you can make
it hey do you need a chair or something
or a drink like a like a cappuccino like
a fraca frappe a mocha kappa some kind
of it right thank you
I deal with this location by the way I
mean the bridge on side the record label
it's just it's genius that's what you do
thank you stick around for the fireworks
oh yeah
excuse me shotgun we all ready ok ok
hang out Lena
it was beautiful but when you do the hip
thing I need like a like a more hit like
a like a like a six year hip like a
bigger sexier hip you'll do it I'm back
alright y'all thank you very much are
you think
[Applause]
hey hey when you guys think I could get
in the studio with you girl Linda Oh
Fred you know I mean she just finished
this to up with Steven Tyler and you
know she's really got to focus on her
solo album maybe next year yeah next
year sure yeah all right
thanks to you great to see you go
[Applause]
what the hell is this don't know you're
under arrest for the murder of Joe Lou
I'm gonna bang your skull like a goddamn
wild man the double D's they're written
in the original book but we didn't have
the character daya
and we'll just play by 103,000 in the
script he was double D number one and I
wanted to work with Andre and so I
called Andre and I said listen I want
you to be in the movie I'll create a
great spot for you
so doc would you turn that mess down
this is the suburbs I'm on the damn
neighborhood watch I figured all I'm
basically playing a rapper you know by
breaking to film I really didn't want to
play a rapper or you know anything
happened to do with music per se we had
a meeting and he said I know you know
dable is this right now but we can
create it and turn into something else
you get on those summers about what 12
miles to the gallon na da boo like it's
a good way well this is my second film
you know and it's all a learning process
I know the more you do it the better you
get
yeah come on up there baby yeah I'm
about watching people means you know sin
you know what was the way they do it you
know I've learned a lot being there just
a great cast from Harvey Keitel and you
know Vince Vaughn and John Travolta Alma
Thurmond they've been doing it for years
you know so they're kind of like vets so
I'm watching them to see you know what
do they do to prepare before they go
into a line and nothing that's a cool
process I told Pistols but at the same
time I may have a pistol and I'm sipping
tea you know rest of my tea on my pistol
so is this all kinds of you know worlds
clash you know and I love it I love it
and Gary pays a lot of attention to
detail it's all these little things
you'll see in movie it maybe like five
or ten years down the line you might be
in the house with your kids and right oh
that's funny
you know I'm just now catching it what
the hell's going on here so you know
he's Gary gray and you know he's a great
guy to work with helping me to get to a
certain mode you know into da boom old
you know and of course Grammy winner
Andre 3000 103,000 you know is voted one
of the most fashionable men on the
planet Earth he wears like chaps and
boas and things that fit Andre Dabu is
so the opposite he wears his clothes
oversized his underwear is always
showing sag and honestly I don't have
any say in da boots look and I think
it's good because they wanted it's pea
you know it's over the top stupid big
Jersey big button chain wear and do a
lot of the sizing you know I probably
would have got everything maybe two or
three sizes smaller I'm style driven you
know and I probably come in and changed
it all up you know but me being a
character I had to kind of submit you
know it's wearing this you know things
that I probably wouldn't you know never
wear or you know just didn't think it
was real fly you know the wear but I'm
playing a character so Dabu chuckles I'm
sure was a stretch for Andre to kind of
really get into the hip hop street thug
thing it was a stretch but you know he
had to do it you know it's a long date
man you'll get a chance to kill somebody
all right calm down got some other stops
to make today I think this is andré
3000's first major role
when he becomes a superstar I want to
take the credit for it I noticed that a
long time ago I told him he should be in
movies now he's in this movie and I know
he's gonna become a really big star so
you heard it right here
I discovered a quick and I want to take
the credit and that's it that's all
[Music]
Leedy there's nothing greater than
seeing John Travolta in the world of
music and the world of dance I mean we
grew up watching him in Greece and
Saturday Night Fever and also in Pulp
Fiction 10 years ago getting to see he
and Huma dance again John talked about
it it almost being like a little Last
Tango in Paris moment between he and uma
it's a sort of captured stolen moment
watching the two of them dance together
when I heard Judge Volta heard music
industry and then obviously Huma
Thurmond I said this is a perfect
setting for a great dancing wizard I
can't name a better actor out today that
can get out like John John loves to
dance whether it's his turn to dance or
not you know we could do a dramatic
scene and it's a musical and John's
gonna dance all the way to the set what
I feel that chilli would be prone to
dance to it be more like a Brazilian
sound like something that has Latin
rhythms it was important for me to bring
in a good person to help with the
choreography tima who is known in the
music industry he's worked with a lot of
big stars was perfect for this I teamed
Fatima up with John they worked on some
dance moves they came back to me and
said hey listen
instead of doing a kind of linear
choreographed piece why don't we pick
five to six specific dances for John and
Newman to do and I'd put it together a
little later on in post that was
exciting I mean growing up watching John
Travolta and all his
movies and dance films and then to be
able to work with him in choreographing
we just got in a room John and I and
just vibe together see what our bodies
naturally did to the song that he picked
out we really came up with some fun
stuff to do it's like working with the
dancer he understands the vocabulary of
dancers and transitions from one move to
the next move and it was lots of fun
well the key was to make it seem
spontaneous because it was a spontaneous
moment between chili and Edie to dance
from Brooklyn it was important for them
to feel comfortable and we got him in
there they started doing their dances
and stuff like that and it was great
[Music]
John is the best partner that you could
get to dance with in the whole world he
makes it so easy he's so passionate he
has so much fun dancing me being more
shy and probably a lot I know a lot less
confident than him
it lets me go and have just a little
time of my life to to do that with him
when I perused through the dance scene I
was like you know I've been here before
I've been in this moment and to dance
with John Travolta it's just so much fun
[Music]
this is the rocks video you ain't woman
enough to take my man and I'm gonna warn
you in advance although it's funny it is
wack and it's everything you shouldn't
do in a music video so just make sure
when you watch it you understand that
it's wrong for a reason and because that
I think is funny check it out
[Music]
you come to tell me something you say I
ought to know he don't love me anymore
and I'll have to let it go you say I'm
gonna take him
oh but I don't think you can
[Music]
you can buy for you
gonna stand by here it'll be over my
dead body
so get out while you can I see the way I
look at my man okay keep it up keep it
up with the song is done
gonna have 245 pounds of feminine ass
whuppin
sometimes a man's God looking at things
that he don't need it took a second look
at you but he's in love with me
well I don't know where that leaves you
home but I know where I stand
[Music]
[Music]
I have to move over and I'm gonna stand
right here
it'll be over my dead body
so
while you can cause you a
my
y'all think if you don't you look at you
- you - I see the way I look at my man
both y'all scandalous scheming just
downright - man feelin
[ __ ] not today not tomorrow not
yesterday you ain't woman enough
and call looking add things that he
don't need like y'all he took a second
look at you but he's in love with me oh
well I don't know where that leaves you
home but I know where I stand
[Music]
anyway
you have to move and I'm gonna stand
right here
it'll be over my dead body
[Music]
while you can call you ain't woman
enough to take my man
[Music]
woman enough to take my man
woman
to take my man
[Music]
not my man
[Music]